well my friends it's wednesday april 6.
we are here we are live it is the h3
podcast
your friend
hold it i want to check audio
i genuinely can't tell if that was a
horse nang or rice guy
was that all rice gum laughing that was
all ricegum yo one of those was legit
straight out of the barn
[Laughter]
sounds like a hoarse name
[Laughter]
guys i'm happy to report i'm feeling
much better today
go
let's go
thank you guys
thank you how are you feeling amy i know
you were a bit under the weather i'm
feeling a lot better yeah i don't know
why i was just tired for two days
straight but i'm better now probably
because you sleep three hours a day yeah
yeah i just maybe caught up with you
yeah you know there's a real thing they
call it a sleep debt it's a scientific
thing sleep death debt oh sleep debt
where your body actually accrues sleep
debt if you don't sleep enough and i
guess you were just paying yeah i paid
on my ban all your debts off debt
collector came ringing
death to all of them it's death
uh today's episode is sponsored by
curology
stamps.com and expressvpn who we all
love so well don't we folks
you know
i didn't poop yesterday
or today yet
thank you dan we did mention that the
you mentioned
last week or last episode that i have my
test results that it was negative it was
negative for the seed the seed delf yeah
positive for dilf
negative
yeah
uh any updates on that you got it no the
doctor was just like listen if you're
dying just come back and we'll give you
another fee and maybe put it you just
had run of the mill poopy butt that's it
i don't know standard issue
due to ass that was not standard issue
we'll see but you know i think i i had a
meal yesterday that cured me
i was drink i've been so hungry because
i haven't been able to eat and i'm still
not eating normal
but
last night or the night before i was
dreaming of this
pasta i wanted to make
and last night
i put my plan into action you guys
i took garlic
celery
onion okay and carrot
right minced it up finely i like where
this was going sauteed it in a huge vat
of olive oil beautiful okay
the aromas are happening
this is where it all you take 10
beautiful big ripe tomatoes
wash them off whatever put them in a
hole
into the oil
add like a cup add a couple cups of
water
boil it all
okay
then i get boil it for about 20 minutes
so the tomatoes are nice and soft and
plump where we like it got myself a
masher
mashed it all down okay
so now what you're left with is this
then you add some basil some oregano
some thyme
some salt a little pepper
and you have i'm telling you you guys
this is this was the most beautiful
naturally he oh and then i added squash
i added yellow
and green squash yeah a whole lot of it
this sounds lovely it was soupy you know
yeah lots of it was very liquidy oh my
god dude you guys it was like just
divine you know it was so good and it
was just like natural beautiful
ingredients i knew everything that was
in it i didn't use anything canned
what kind of pasta
uh i use the shells
little scoopers that's great with what
you're describing yeah because you want
all that broth absolutely
i ate around the pasta if i'm being
honest
it was just all about that bro i want to
just cook it again just the soup and
drink the sauce but boy boy boy why are
you laughing at maybe
i'm i was just thinking about my own
dinner
what'd you have we had tacos and they
gave us salsa verde and it was like on
the table i mean lena kind were looking
at it we put it on the floor because we
don't want to look at it because
reminding us of something
we had to put it on the floor put it
like yeah there's a container like next
to where we eat because our table is low
in the living room okay and then i was
like looking at it it was still just
looking at me we i had to throw it away
the curse
i've been seeing really funny post on
the subway people been like he room i
see him everywhere and it's just pesto
there's [ __ ] all over the floor
so i'm still not 100 but i'm feeling
much better actually
keem starts crying and [ __ ] right
now yeah
he had his best god i prayed for him to
die
i thought you had finally answered my
prayers
yeah i mean i've never had somebody
publicly um
wish for my death like that so that was
interesting
outcome of all that can't wait to report
your death
yeah well you'll have to wait another
day [ __ ]
not today
yeah so you know feeling much better i
was eating food keeping it down
you know
it was nice i got to spend time with the
kids finally
got to hang out with bruce finally and
theodore and
it was great
picked up theodore from school yesterday
with the dogs it was awesome your boy
bruce has a hell of a belch in him
when i was over there the other oh you
heard him yeah man it's like an adult
man burp well those babies they chug at
this they chug the formula and then
that's the burping is real man they say
you got to burp the babies it's a real
thing
they just get very uncomfortable ah
yeah he's a he's a big belcher
i mean theodore's starting to rip ass
where we're like was that you bro like
[ __ ] a monster rip
my father like son
crazy
yeah so
love is back in sweden love i see you
we've got you adorned with g-fuel
oh yeah
wait is that in our in our studio oh
yeah it is where's my sponsor bro
where's the g fuel sponsor yeah turn
that around real quick yeah they need to
pay for that damn
the only reason it's there is because
it's pewdiepie's uh of course are you
representing okay my swedish brothers
there's some lincoln berry g fuel you
know god damn rasco whoa whoa whoa whoa
you see there he's there
that's watch your back
and you have access to all the filters
and stuff on that tv
yes but uh for whatever reason they've
all been reset resetted so i'm working
on gathering all my old stuff back
so let's see here
boom mustache oh kitty's back baby
the comedy is back
and you're wearing a jack-in-the-box um
hat yep is that a uh yep
[Applause]
directly from jack himself i also got a
signed jack-in-the-box picture
very cool
oh hell yeah i didn't even know you ate
it jack-in-the-box do you like
jack-in-the-box that's one of the i
would say lower tier fast foods and
apologies it's yeah it's it's a bit
lower tier but it's quick quick and easy
and they're open late late they're open
like 24 too expensive
man that place it's all right
i mean look bro people that go to jack
in the box no it sucks
that's why people go there no okay what
do you eat there right well honestly
nothing but it like if i'm in a what
oh i i mean i'm defending a place you
don't you don't even like anything hold
on can i can i finish please sure
whenever i feel like going to have a pig
out you always go get tacos and they're
milkshakes i'm just saying tacos is
youtube sponsored by jack in the box
wait wait wait wait wait wait
how many times have you used your gift
card yet be honest zero
what the [ __ ] bro you're sitting here
i've used my gift for card seven times
wow
and i always shared with cam so that's a
lot of meals and
i gotta say it's all right it's all
right oh yeah the the jack in the box
you shook them down right love how did
that go they yeah they were trying to
like get some free clout i
they got a lot of free clap from sac
that's for sure they started with me
to me i put my foot down i told them
like
i won't play ball unless you send me a
gift card for multiple a hundreds
dollars and they came through and see
now we're talking about them so wait how
much should they end up sending you 250
250
that's a lot of jack in the box [ __ ]
yeah that's like a thousand tacos
yeah i'm gonna you could feed skid row
with that money
yeah i don't i don't know when i'm gonna
use it but um yeah i don't know if you
want to damn if you gave the people on
skid row those jack-in-the-box tacos i
don't think they make it through the
night though yeah
like they're just you know what i mean
they need they need some of that awesome
jack-in-the-box tacos
i don't get the jack-in-the-box tacos i
think they're disgusting and repulsive
and people that like them i've just
never understood that i just find them
people are like right it's utterly uh
repulsive yeah now they're disgusting
have you tried the mini tacos
it's the same [ __ ] love no it's not it's
like a little hot pocket have you tried
a taco
yes yes so i mean i'm just saying the
the big ones don't hit but the like like
the mini ones they're like you get 30
tacos for three bucks dude how do they
not what do you mean they don't that's
not food do you understand what you just
said if you get 30 of something three
bucks how did they not hit love what do
you mean by that
all right
listen they didn't pay us enough we're
talking about jack in the box you need
to send me a gift card for ten thousand
dollars
she plays songs
shout out to jack
cam uh came i'm just gonna represent cam
here he says it's all trash other than
their curly fries so there you go
cameron the curly fries are okay
i'll give them tama's been eating for
free dude
you're not one to talk damn it's trash i
am one to talk i had it
yeah all right all right yeah you say
that
but
okay i also have a video
uh of love complaining about his jack in
the box too i'll play it oh
what was the complaint cameron he was
pissed uh love hates cheese
right and he was fuming that they gave
him cheese on his burger well that's a
user here is this what you want yeah
that didn't
make me scrape off my own cheese hold on
yeah there's why we cannot play the
audio i was very mad he just wanted to
you know eat some yak and watch some
nina
you know
yeah all right
thank you i'm not i don't i'm not
usually that mad but i was looking
forward to this genuine anger
yeah this is me okay now
isn't her innocence
there at 10 o'clock scraping [ __ ]
sheets of my burger bro with a fork at
home
you don't appreciate it
you got to work on that cheese phobia
dude
no i don't know you're going to lose
your eu citizenship you can't you can't
be anti-cheese and be european okay well
anyway you're back in sweden now you've
been posting pictures of you in the snow
are you missing the sunshine are you
happy to be back home in a way back at
your setup you know
i mean it's nice being back at my setup
yeah i love my setup but i don't like
the snow and the cold no yeah
anyone here from arizona we got to catch
you some gators
out here
i want to go to someone and catch some
gators
you know there's no gators in arizona
right
that's been brought to my attention okay
just making sure
i mean you don't live here so i don't
expect you to know the geography but
arizona's uh
i'd say probably over half of americans
don't know that either to be fair gators
in arizona
i mean there's no water there there's
lit yeah
there's literally no
the first thing about geography to to
know that though which most people here
don't so i'm sure there's a gate over
there
probably on a zoo maybe yeah it's
probably a gator yeah i guess that's
true
there's there's got to be a gator
yes
anyway
well let's get on with the show we got a
lot to talk about we do
um
we have a special guest calling in
around uh three
uh that's true
[Music]
which i'm not gonna say now you're gonna
have to wait and see
but let's just look we got all kinds of
stuff so let's check
chickadee dude
did you get it joe biden
joel biden
uh poor joe biden
i don't know what's happening here
but i saw this and well
he just faces the
back and uh
look obama's there
and uh
i'm sorry but that is a [ __ ] that is
straight up grandpa is lost if i've ever
seen it
i interpreted it more that his feelings
are hurt that everybody's so excited to
see barack and nobody's paying attention
oh is barack back there yeah dude
oh yeah they're all they're all hovering
around
yeah
i see what's happening he's like hey i'm
the pr i'm president remember guys
in truth he's still barack's vice
president when barack shows up you know
what i mean you're still vp
you fall in line
[Music]
where am i
[Music]
god damn he's old
and it get hot i got lana i got hairy
legs
now
listen i don't mind joe biden you know i
think for the most part he's he's doing
his best and
he's a good faith actor
that's fine that being said the man is
so [ __ ] can we stop with the old i
just i can't guys we we can't be a
country run by 80 year olds
yeah have you
can't do this every time
you ever you've seen my mom who's like
my mom is uh
she's in her 50s okay she's young
compared to joe biden that woman took an
hour to attach an email
to touch an image in the email you think
joe biden knows how to send a [ __ ]
email hell no
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
no wake up
look how sad he looks at the end there
you have freeze frame on the then
no respect
but you know
don't let people convince you by the way
that that donald trump is somehow like
younger and snappier than
donald trump's also old as [ __ ] so
it's not about that donald trump age
man is 75 years old yeah compared to
biden who's 79.
those four years make a big diff at that
age though i'll be honest you know what
i mean oh yeah well i mean
if you go back and watch any of the
videos of biden right at the end of the
obama administration
it's a different person yeah like a long
time ago
those four years that trump was in
office he uh lost a step or two or three
or four
five he lost the whole stairs yeah he
fell down the stairs
i mean you know
that's a lot of there's a lot to be
dealing with okay god bless him you know
love long long live the queen or
whatever the [ __ ] they say that about
joe biden
um so there you go shout out to our dear
beloved president who is trying to find
his bingo card
he's trying to find the bingo host he's
ready to play and nobody will put
just shut up and sit down
uh jordan peterson as you know is a
[ __ ] idiot
love the [ __ ] on him on the show
his fans are all dumbasses and losers
it's true
um
jordan peterson sells basic intro to
psychology
packaged with uh
alpha maleness he really is kind of an
incel
you know show you something here
i saw this on my tick tock feed this guy
pops up on my feed from time time he's a
biblical historian he really knows his
stuff
and
he really just
eviscerated uh jordan here which i
thought was great
i want to show you something here
all right let's see it
at the bottom here
every single one of those lines is a
biblical verse
okay
now the length of the line is
proportionate to how many times that
verse is referred to in some way by some
other verse
so you say well this is the first
hyperlinked book
so the bible did not become a book until
about the third or the fourth century c
e
when all these separately circulating
texts were brought together
and combined into a single text but for
literally thousands of years authors had
been writing texts
that were internally self-referential
and that referred to other texts within
a broader tradition that from which they
were borrowing or that they were quoting
and in many cases these texts were later
brought together
into a single text so there is no sense
whatsoever in which the bible was the
first hyperlinked book
i want to show you something yeah again
what does that even mean right
like
self-referential book i don't i don't
even know but yeah he's just a [ __ ]
the bible was the first quote tweet the
the bible was the first
important novel
that
talked about the problems that men have
and it was used in a book huh
the bible was talking about poor men
king david for example he only got the
[ __ ] one [ __ ]
he was a king for christ's sake he
should have been [ __ ] many [ __ ]
if i was a king i'd [ __ ] everybody
uh king david had eight wives he had
eight wives you should have had five he
should have had a hundred
do you know how much trouble comes with
eight wives damn he really had eight
wives good for him i mean according to
david the wikipedia page for david
so what do i know i guess they weren't
into monogamy yet because that's part of
the whole jewish thing uh
yeah he may be uh
he was uh a men going their own way he's
like
he's a sigma david was the first sigma
really
yeah and then uh jordan was
if you guys didn't know anything about
andy
goh
he is one of the biggest pieces of shits
on the internet this guy is a
provocateur he's a liar he's a
propagandist
and you know jordan peterson now he has
no problem talking to anyone that will
listen to him
uh
curious journalist andy go ask professor
jordan peterson how psychology can
explain why antifa is so evil and bad
jordan peterson says it's revenge
against god for the crime of being dude
really thinks he's in like a marvel
movie
[Laughter]
he thinks they're all like hannibal
lecter yeah oh you know what that is
that's like a attack on titan psychology
hmm
oh
and then he starts crying
this is a psychologist bro and his
actual analysis is there it's a cr their
revenge against god for the crime of
being
can you imagine
that's your analysis
but also
i'll tell you what bro this been look at
this [ __ ] guy dude
based on your your
your knowledge about brand new clinical
experience what what is the
psychology of this mob violence
when i see it it it
like i i don't even recognize some of
these it seems they seem animalistic is
what i mean oh um oh like you see them
as subhuman perhaps is that another way
that you might describe that animalistic
definitely but you know i love how
jordan he always goes about like i've
studied the nazis uh the biggest part of
my career and he he can go into all
these incredible explanations explain
the ideology of nazis
but when it comes to antifa
who basically was antifa done throwing a
milkshake in andy's face broke some [ __ ]
i mean you know you can but like he's
like they're animals
they're they're angry for existing
the nazis you see was a very
interesting i can and that
the from this first world war and this
and it's so in the animals
no they're worse than animals they're
worse they're worse than animals because
animals they just kill to eat you know
human beings they have a twist in them
that makes them far worse than animals
when they really get going well i think
it's i think you really want to know
what i think i think it's revenge
against god for the crime of being
that's my professional analysis oh okay
i have a phd
animals
that's really what i think
it's kane and cain and abel it's like oh
abel's your abel's your guy hey god how
about if i take him out in the field and
beat him to death
how do you feel about that
all my sacrifices went
unrewarded
yeah it's like
yeah that's what it is at the bottom of
the hell of things
bro you are so unwell oh my god jesus
needs help to be honest in a non in a in
a way that's actually not funny is
this type of thinking like you noted dan
of seeing these people as sub-human and
that's what really is doing he's saying
they have no motivation they're beneath
animals he says they have no motivation
[Music]
they only want to destroy things for the
crime of existing
and then well once you once you've
categorized them like that you can
literally justify doing anything to them
that's right
and and that's you know that's the real
[ __ ] right there
it's not like you know our society is
broken it's not that you know people go
into bankruptcy to pay their health care
bills it's not that people
of younger generations are and less
likely to own a house it's not that
people can't find [ __ ]
uh well good wage jobs it's not it's not
that elon musk can on a whim just spend
10 billion dollars to buy twitter but
meanwhile those [ __ ] like
20 000 people just on skid row
it's the crime of existing
you know what i mean
you're a psychologist man that's your
[ __ ] job
damn i don't think it really is anymore
does he practice anymore i i don't i
genuinely don't know i know that he
doesn't teach anymore right he was he
he quit at the university of toronto
so i can't imagine he just does this all
day he just cries and interviews with
pieces of [ __ ]
top top comment take note psychology
students
yeah
wait this is an actual diaphragm from
his book diagram yeah
what the [ __ ] is this uh
yeah
it's a little beyond the scope of this
podcast but it
and i've i've listened to a few other
podcasts
yeah yeah
his his books
are [ __ ] insane
the rules for life i think this one is
from uh maps of minds or
map mind mapping meaning or i forget
yeah
it's from
it's the book prior to the the 12 rules
of life one that he wrote but it's it's
full of just totally [ __ ] insane
diagrams like this that are impossible
to follow okay so we have yahweh
god
we have the pre-cosmetic egg
right
which we all know what that means
uh uh
uh yeah the void
uh matter and sexual creative union
so yahweh
god
and the void are having sex
what the [ __ ] bro and then you have a
chaos dragon you got the venus you got a
damn i think actually uh
i think he's actually interpreting the
story of elden ring right here right i
think so
yeah i think uh maps of meaning thank
you chatter who uh
who got it there the feminine dragon of
chaos is the subtitle for that so
cool
it eats its own tail
all right well there you have it
yeah
uh bonus one more bonus of jordan
peterson crying because i can't get
enough um
you know there was a point where he was
interesting
i think and and maybe acted in better
faith you know
but i feel like he's just so off the
deep end that he can't be taken
seriously and at any you know at any
capacity
i mean the the the the constant crying
in every interview does
kind of indicate to me there's
he's unwell yeah he's like really
nothing wrong with crying crying is is
beautiful and it's great but like crying
crying at anything at the drop of a hat
over everything is a symptom of yeah
it's something weird something's off
yeah he's like depressed or yeah he's
just not well he just went through that
uh severe drug addiction too and was in
a coma for a while it's like yeah the
dude's dude's not well
and everyone is so
taken by that that it just lifts them
out of the
normality of their existence you know
they see this joy just transfuse them
and that's because they got an
intimation of genuine meaning
and it's uh and it's it's it's not
amenable to rational criticism which is
the thing that i thought that struck me
is so miraculous about music and wise
has this element of salvation it's like
he's crying about you directly in touch
with the meaning that sustains you in
life direct like i get it you know music
dub yeah music great
music
man we've all been there bro we'll get
it take you places yeah it's sick
yeah i mean it's yeah you know it's okay
to cry it's okay to cry but when when
you're sobbing in literally every media
appearance that you make
it might be indicative that you need to
conversion therapy is moral
grandstanding
where would we be without king david and
his 25 wives
only eight
do david do dirty like that hey can i
get some of that fiddlehead coffee
fiddlehead baby thank you
anyway i don't get stuck on a topic too
long let's move let's just keep moving
along we have a quick one because we're
getting near brick yeah i do um um
more james charles cringe i love this
man i saw this comment on twitter and
it's true this [ __ ] keeps
popping up and the comment said how's
this dude anywhere but in prison and i
agree
james charles being annoyed due to being
fined for not following simple rules
okay james
something that i simply just did not
understand is how as a society we have
agreed to just let airlines get away
with scamming people so i'm at the
airport checking in for my flight as per
usual and i put my bag on the scale
before checking it and she goes oh sorry
babe it's 51 pounds it's gonna be 100
i said you can't just let it slide
please he goes no sorry it's overweight
you're gonna have to pay 100 or take
something out i said absolutely [ __ ]
not am i paying 100 for this so i
unzipped my bag i removed one pair of
socks one sole pair of socks and a
straightening iron zip it back up put it
back on let's go magically 49 pounds
i need my scale at home to lie to me
like that because that is some [ __ ]
i could understand if it was like a
gravity thing and they're like oh the
bags are too heavy so the plane is
literally going to
fall out of the sky like obviously we
don't want that to happen but how could
it be a gravity thing if the bags are
still going on the plane they're just
below the plane as opposed to an
overhead compartment it's still equally
as heavy it's not going to tip over
like what the [ __ ]
it's a lot my god thank you sam
brave of you'd even to even complain
about anything
considering you're not on chris hanson
right now yeah so embarrassing well
i guess we do know that he has oh that
[ __ ] he has a hard time uh
wrapping his head around numbers so
okay
this is the first cup of coffee i've had
in two weeks by the f this is the
official coffee of the h3 podcast this
is our boy
and his wife fiddlehead
who called in a few weeks ago
at this point i don't know
who's uh battling a brain tumor
and the boy he sent us so much coffee
he hooked it the [ __ ] oh man this coffee
is good and um
i haven't done enough
this week
but i'm just looking yeah uh last
we saw thanks to all the fupa troopers
uh
it was um
1500 families
uh with a week of meals medical care
counseling and assistance for safe
housing in ukraine
um
thanks to you all it's probably higher
than that now because that was uh
yeah that was a couple weeks ago this is
the best cup of coffee i've ever had
first one in weeks
beautiful top of the mug to you
shout out to patrick once again
where everything is going
yeah i mean james you know
james
where do i begin
i love that it's on cringe topia
yeah i mean by the way he he describes
he goes one pair of socks
and then
a
kind of like mutter muddy really fast a
straightening iron yeah straightening
iron definitely weighs a pound yeah
for sure that'll do it so i don't even
know what you're tripping bro
also
i've packed when i moved to israel you
know we we were overweight
the 50 pound that you have to pack that
suitcase so [ __ ] full to hit that man
what do you got in there little kid
you can't just let it slide please
you know what i mean
also
also if you're you know just
how hard is it to back light james
you're not human trafficking
that's all i'm saying
because that what's that like 25 pounds
alone so
yeah leave the kids in your basement and
you'll have plenty of weight left over
in your backpack in your suitcase just
saying well that makes more sense why he
got so mad why he didn't want it to get
checked yeah he's like [ __ ] just one
sock he's like [ __ ] just one stay quiet
in there
yes
he was using that
sock to stuff in the mouth keep them
quiet oh is there someone roasting him
in the background yeah did you not
notice that
let me tell you something that i simply
just did not understand so i was kind of
shocked at how brazen he is just to do
this like right at the check-in line
like man you got no shame doug and it's
how as a society we have a brief time
against
scamming people so i'm at the airport
checking in for my flight as per usual
and i put my bag on the scale before
checking in and she goes oh sorry this
guy knew he's about to be on tick tock
maybe a hundred dollars
i said you can't just let it slide
please he goes no
[ __ ] are you special or something james
i did you really think you were special
like can you let it slide
how about you slide into prison where
you belong
[ __ ]
maybe she heard little screams for help
just hitting the panic button just
trying to keep you there long enough
i'm sorry it's overweight you're gonna
have to pay 100 or take something out i
said absolutely [ __ ] not am i paying
100 for this so i unzipped my bag i
removed one pair of socks one sole pair
of socks [ __ ] and then what
emphasized the sock and then what [ __ ]
and a straightening iron
oh shut the [ __ ] up
before you do that why don't you just
have a seat right over there yeah
exactly
take out that straightener and go ahead
and have a seat there james you [ __ ]
sick
[ __ ] why don't you take a seat right
over there somebody uh donated 10 and
said real talk speaks more to how james
was treating the employees i've been
flying a lot over the past six months
and i've seen plenty of people allowed
overweight baggage for free but they
were nice true
yep
i also got a vouch for that i've been a
little bit times i've been a bit over
and they're like oh don't worry about it
if he was really one pound over i feel
like they wouldn't have cared
they're like is mr why is your
suitcase begging to call the police
right now
[Laughter]
also [ __ ] i know you can afford that
hundred just shut up stop complaining
like you're poor
what was on the agenda tonight yeah
what's on the agenda tonight
zip it back up put it back on the scale
magically 49 pounds
i need my scale at home that's not magic
[ __ ] that's a curling iron look up on
amazon how much a curling iron weighs or
a flat iron or whatever the hell he said
but it's like a pound and a half and
that sock's so damn crusty for me jizzy
and it's got at least half a pound in
that
so no uh cookies for you
some soggy coffee keys maybe i'm seeing
on average 1.4 pounds [ __ ]
one and a half pounds
[ __ ] [ __ ]
right there
and look at you trying to throw shade at
the employee and [ __ ]
hell no
i love that you can't even i'm laughing
because you big mad
oh by the way um
guest on friday brittany broski that's
right
just remembered i just want to get every
let everyone know super excited brittany
broski in the studio friday tell all
your friends evidently big fan because
she
she reached out to us
she was tagging us on twitter we wanted
to have her on we wanted to have her on
anyways and then she just coincidentally
uh tagged us on twitter
and uh demanded to be led on the podcast
and like okay demand i saw her in the
full rick and morty sweatsuit and all
that i think i think i'm excited
brittany broski all chat seems very
excited for that very excited let's go
yeah people are excited
first guest in a while
other than that [ __ ] dick all over
seeing lots of yasses
let's get those yases going
oh yeah here she is i love her
she's so cool and nice she's oh my gosh
yes
i wonder who took this screenshot
oh boy
i might have done that yes
ski
oh i saw you had the kebab pizza how was
that
oh so it was good nice
yeah really good i really want to try
that thing man
uh i wish i could send it to you yeah
is there a way for him to sail to you to
mail
if he like flash freezes it last freeze
i mean i wouldn't be
i mean
yeah i guess and then we have all the
infinite resources right like
theoretically
well i'm not going to spend
it
if someone can do it it's you ethan yes
but let's make it happen
well we'll think about it i'm not done
roasting you james you think i'm done
you [ __ ]
something that i simply did iron zip it
back up put it back on this gun
magically 49 pounds
i'm i just did the math you [ __ ] ain't
nothing magic about that
yeah james just thinks it's magic when
the number's a little smaller than uh
than you thought it was
they said it was 18 but it was actually
uh 16 and a half it's like magic
just one and a half
years pounds what's the difference i
need my scale at home to lie to me like
that because that is some [ __ ] i
could understand if it was like a
gravity thing and they're like oh the
bags are too heavy so the plane is
literally going to
fall out of the sky like obviously we
want that to happen but how could it be
a gravity thing if the bags are still
going on the plane they're just below
the plane as opposed to an overhead
compartment it's still equally as heavy
it's not going to tip over
okay jerry seinfeld
trying to do comedy or some [ __ ]
sir is there a reason you're about uh
suitcase is uh
asking uh to free them
stop laughing it's not funny
[Music]
why do billionaires always complain
about small fees like 100 bucks
i don't know if he's just trying to
appeal to like the commoners you know
what i mean
i also care about a hundred dollars just
like you
seems like it's more of a principle
thing
yeah
well you have it feeling entitled to uh
skirt the rules
well i wonder why let's um
by the way people ask him where's drew i
don't know we're trying to res she
needed to reschedule i'll let you guys
yeah
there's a tentative date i guess i won't
say though because it's not 100
confirmed but it would be
it's it'll be in a couple months
that was
you know
a couple months she's busy
so we're just happy to have her in right
[Applause]
is that right guys absolutely
right that's right that's right anytime
she comes in is a blessing to me that's
right
that's right people
all right let's thank our beautiful
sponsors guys let's do it if you love
the podcast you will consider supporting
any of these sponsors
curology who i love
listen guys i'm not blowing smoke i use
curology every day
it's my go-to i absolutely love it what
is it so curology is a game-changing
custom skin care made for you by
dermatology provider they create a
custom prescription cream for your
specific goals whether it's tackling
acne clogged pores skin texture dark
spots fine lines or something else
you stay you all you got to do is take
an online quiz
upload photos of your skin
and if it's a good fit they're going to
ship you a custom formula right to your
door
it's even got your name on the bottle
i absolutely love it you know
they sent me three products you get the
face wash
the dermatology provided cream
and the moisturizer what's great is dude
going to the dermatology dermatologist
sucks it's a pain in the ass even if
you've got health insurance you want to
do it from that you got to get a
reference and a referral takes all this
time if you do it private it's so
expensive
this is the way to do it man you know if
you want that that professional care on
your skin this is the way to do it
it's cheaper
it's easier it's sent right to your door
and the products themselves are freaking
fantastic like i said i use them every
day
you don't have to think about it i
really do i i can't recommend it enough
and with the offer they have here it's
really a no-brainer
get started with curology just like i
did
with a free 30-day trial at curology.com
h3 and here's the deal you just pay five
bucks
for shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
spelled that right right
see you one more
i think so c-u-r-o-l-o-g
dot com h3 there you go start your free
30-day trial you can cancel any time and
the prescription is subject to
consultation but yeah i love curology
guys consider
uh checking it out thank you
samps.com
if you mail stuff and you're not using
stamps.com you are literally playing
yourself
i love stamps.com you know time is money
and you don't waste uh either with rich
repeated trips to the post office with
stamps.com you skip the trip and you
focus on taking your small business to
the next level stamps.com lets you print
official postage right from your
computer saves you money in the process
you can spend less time at the post
office and more time making your
customers happy
you know
the thing is
we've talked about a million times um
dan's uh girlfriend ollie actually mails
her
art with put with stamp stuff all right
she uses it for small business her
skirts art.com and uh she ships
everything with stamps.com just prints
the postage straight from her desk slaps
it on an envelope and drops in the mail
slot it's so not easier the thing is
they provide you a scale
so you weigh it
you print it on your computer it's all
connected it's super easy you put it on
and then they come pick it up
and that so like it couldn't be easier
in that regard then the other thing is
they also get you huge discounts you
can't find anywhere else like 40 off ups
rates and 76 percent off ups again no
frickin brainer dude this is one of
these great services that's just
impossible to be
you know if you're doing an etsy side
hustle a full-blown warehouse
uh
or just sending invoices stamps.com is
gonna make your life easier all you need
is a computer and a standard printer
there's no special supplies or equipment
[Music]
you're up and running in minutes
printing official postage for any letter
any package anywhere you want to send
stop overpaying for shipping with
stamps.com
sign up with the promo code h3 for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial
free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and enter code h3
thank you to stamps.com we love you
and finally a big thank you to
expressvpn
going online with that expressvpn is
like
is like using your smartphone without a
protective case most of the time you're
probably going to be fine but all it
takes is one accidental drop onto solid
concrete and it make you wish that you
had protected
yourself you know it's like go it's like
pulling out
usually it's fine all it takes is one
damn kid and you'll be wishing you were
wearing a condom
no glove no love
you know what i'm saying
people think they're so good at pulling
out and all of a sudden oh you got a
[ __ ] kid and now you're married to
someone you don't even like
[Music]
telling you expressvpn
expressvpn guys every time you connect
to an unencrypted network in cafes
hotels airports etc your online data is
not secured
any hacker on the same network can gain
access to and steal your personal data
talking about passwords financial
details etc it doesn't take much
technical knowledge to hack someone
either just some cheap hardware
a smart 12 year old could do it
hackers can make up to a thousand
dollars per person selling your personal
info on the dark web hell no
that's why you got to use expressvpn
they create uh encrypted tunnels
to encrypt your data
between the device and the internet and
so hackers can't steal your sensitive
data
also it's super secure take a hacker
with a super computer over a billion
years to get past expressvpn's
encryption damn
did they say a billion years
better start working now
better off just mining by bitcoin
easy to use you can fire it up on an app
and click one button and all of a sudden
boom you're protected and works on all
devices phones
laptops tablets and more
and you can stay secure on the go i like
expressvm because it's basically the
most reputable one it's easy to use it's
a great product you know it's used by
lots of people
and
it's fast
i love expressvpn you know go with the
go with the big boys go with the uh
with the product like this go with the
one that's you know
well known and loved that's why i like
expressvpn it's fast too
so secure your online data today
by going to expressvpn.com h3 that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
h3 and you can get an extra three months
for free wow
expressvpn.com h3 thank you so much to
our sponsors guys
uh check them out
thank you for helping us make this show
great
there you have it
you know i gotta say something
i've been watching a lot of real
housewives
a lot
had a lot of free time lately with my
illness and stuff
or just sitting there you know
it seems to me
so much trouble in these women's lives
comes down to not using a condom i'm
just i'm just being real with you guys
at home because there's a lot of young
people watching younger than me
i mean sexually active people i'm
telling you you do not i'm just you
please use a condom
okay i'm telling you your whole you can
just control your own destiny man did
you bring condoms you don't want to have
a kid with someone you don't
like and you don't want that for your
kid either i promise you just it's not
worth it to not use a condom or to pull
out what the [ __ ] i'm just saying
protect your future damn it
please i watch this i think you'll
please if the show wouldn't even exist
and people just use condoms which is a
problem for me because i like the shows
right
careful what you wish for
all right we have oliver tree on the
phone what does he want
way to ruin the surprise
i know he's calling in and i know he
wants to tell me something so let's
bring him on
all right one sec
yeah oliver tree's been bugging me
so here's oliver tree
whoa
if that is your real name
and he's been hitting me up non-stop
uh basically all week when can i get on
the show when can i get on the show when
can i i said bro i don't know i've got
[ __ ] bigger problems than whatever
the [ __ ] you want to pitch
you just walked off
practically begging me so now he has
opportunity and he's just walking off
camera i don't know what he's doing he
didn't even get his [ __ ] audio to
work right now i just heard him laugh
i can't hear [ __ ] dude okay well then
figure it out bro you're honest you're
on a you're on one of the biggest
podcasts in the world if you get your
tech [ __ ] out before you call in [ __ ]
i've been waiting for an hour dude how
have you been waiting for an hour i told
you to call in at three you're five
minutes early
well dude i just wanted to say
i know we haven't always seen eye to eye
and i know we've had our differences but
after my tour i've taken some time to
check out your podcast and
you know
your jokes are funny dude whoa and some
of the stuff you guys are saying
i think it aligns with some of my
beliefs as well and i think you know
deep down ethan you are funny man you
are a funny guy wow wow that's really
nice that's kind of unexpected
thank you and by the way is that a teddy
fresh hoodie
yeah
oh damn you look good bro your hair
looks good too you're doing some good
upkeep on the hair
yeah i'm experimenting with uh
some different types of hair products
and i'm not really supposed to talk
about that right now but how any loose
ends there how that how the ends on that
on the hair
very good nice
yeah no loose ends split ends i think
they're called yeah
so anyway well okay so you're buttering
me up what the [ __ ] dude you here just
to compliment me or what
well
i i did want to say something there is
one thing um
i don't know if you know this but i got
nominated for a really prestigious award
oh
was it the uh
okay i don't i don't know if you go go
ahead what'd you get nominated for
well you may have heard about it but
i
i don't know how to say this is a really
big moment and i'm super excited okay
okay
i was nominated
for a kid's choice award nickelodeon
are you kidding me
no
i'm serious
is he for real a kid's choice award what
what kids is listening to oliver tree
bro i got lots of kids fans after that
life goes on e99
so is that why you're complimenting me
what do you want me to do about it you
think that i kept
well
i thought maybe
you could tell some of your fans maybe
that they could help support the vision
and this could be big man i've been in a
rough patch you know i don't know if you
know this but
my grandmother kicked me off of a ranch
and i've actually been living at my
manager's house on a bean bag and you
know shit's just kind of it's been rough
and
i feel like if i really won this award
like this could really
this could make my career come back man
and i feel like i don't want to be a
beggar but like bro did it did your
music videos get like
age restricted for having like a
decapitated head in it like how is that
that's not even like kid friendly
yeah that did happen i also had one that
was recently age restricted for
making out with a bunch of grandmas oh
was that age restricted
yeah yeah we got them to lift the band
but
they really put a hard swing on it okay
wait let me confirm that this is
actually real let's see
um i'm seeing
i went to their website to vote it
forces you to to vote category by
category like you can't like skip ahead
to see
these are last year's winners what am i
doing oh okay
wait how do i vote yeah okay vote now i
gotta i don't even believe so what
what the [ __ ] is this you have to your
favorite i gotta vote for all this [ __ ]
i know it's a little obnoxious i mean
this is you're actually asking to do our
fans to do a lot of work apparently yo
what is this bro this is some dog [ __ ]
they don't even care about you they're
just using you to vote for some dumb ass
crap dude you really want this award
bro i need this like i am i'm down bad
all right i'm just gonna click
i'm just it would mean the world okay so
i just got to to male artist uh i see
bruno mars justin bieber the weeknd ed
sheeran drake and shawn mendes are any
of those you
no no that's not the category
what's the category okay wait
uh i'm gonna vote for
hold on favorite tv star olivia
rodriguez
favorite male tv star are you in this
category no this guy's not that one
either
this guy's like 60. okay i'm gonna vote
for the six year old
favorite female tv star
let's go with
miranda cosgrove because of the [ __ ]
meme
okay when do when do i see you
i'm coming up man any minute
okay i'm just this is so you guys if you
want to vote for oliver you're gonna
have to do all this favorite video game
that's before your ass okay minecraft
favorite movie
oh jesus bro
those are good ones i actually like that
selection
okay i'm just clicking random [ __ ]
favorite movie actor that's not
obviously vin diesel yeah talk to me
kids
zendaya obviously
animated movie dude they put your ass
like in the back bro no it's uh well
it wasn't one of the bigger categories
we could say that but it's still a
nomination and you know i've never been
nominated what's the category favorite
white trash
fake ass country loser
hey come on now
let's keep it light man you said you'd
be nice
i didn't say that
dan said you'd be nice and you know i
mean after everything i've done for your
show over the years you know it's the
least you could do
oh my god how many [ __ ] i gonna click
bro yeah i went through best male artist
best female artist best friend i gotta
do 22 pages before i get to your ad stop
just dude you're almost there anytime
i'm trying to help you but this is
ridiculous i'm just clicking okay
favorite breakout artist wait are you on
you're not a breakout artist no i wasn't
a breakout artist
okay
okay favorite album
okay you're not on this season is this
award ceremony he's gonna be like three
hours favorite social music stars oh
favorite
social music star the hell does that
mean there he is
all right let's see who are you up
against jojo suiwa
addison ray
that girl lele
you want to talk [ __ ] about any of your
uh
competitors
i think they're all great options but i
think that you know the underdog is
definitely me and i'm the only guy who's
you know really a country artist that's
ever been nominated for a kid's choice
award so i think you know we can make
history together that's all i would say
but you know the competition incredible
options but please man i really need
your help with this again i gotta ask
are they gonna hand this out during the
show or is this one of those yeah this
is that they're gonna give like this is
definitely an it's like
yeah
no no this is a legit one they said that
if i win i get slimed on national
television and come on dude don't you
want to see that don't you come over my
house i'll slime you in private
bro come on okay well all right let me
be honest now you know i'm an honest
person right i'm giving you the
publicity so saying my favorite social
music star
i mean between dixie
dixie to emilia on oliver tree
addison race you got bangers you heard
that dixie one i was really really
really really sad
yeah that [ __ ] slaps harder than i need
99
come on man and then that girl lelay was
she she got a good hit she's got some
fire fire
oh yeah yeah she's she's actually really
good layla he's an amazing artist oh
jojo's though is pretty i mean jojo's on
top of the world how are you gonna be
joking
i don't know man that's why i need your
help
all right you know what i'm not even
gonna do a meme and vote for dixie i'm
actually going to vote for oliver
the only reason no idea
the only reason i'm actually voting for
you is because you're going to [ __ ]
owe me dude
what do you mean oh you yeah
if you went you're not even going to win
dude i don't know but i'm going to vote
for you
everybody go spend an hour of your time
clicking through all these [ __ ]
categories it's literally three minutes
i voted you know what you know what if
you win if you win
i want the blimp
i'm giving you the blimp to you and
theodore
and michael or whatever your other side
michael
it's bruce bro come on what the [ __ ]
what kind of fake ass fan are you
[Laughter]
bro how are you going to be addison ray
she's like a bajillion okay everyone go
vote for you promise you'll give me that
blimp
i promise you okay
everybody giving us the blend he needs
it we got it
i need seven minutes i need all the wait
let me say this i you can actually vote
as many times as you want you just have
to finish the voting process
not kidding dude so you
you have to finish
i did it on like 20 computers and
i have a setup
excuse me
that was donald trump saying huge
massive dumps i believe they call them
dumps huge dumps of votes
look
i you know i love the hd podcast i have
been supporting you guys since name my
new my name my son's name
michael yeah
and dude you know what i'm a legit fan
like i actually prefer
some of the side channels like i'm a big
fan of av stock killer like he's gonna
win this fight i'm gonna be rooting for
this guy from the beginning no don't
turn it off all right he's got he's got
my vote
huge supporter and um you know i have to
say this man i really need this i'm down
bad right now this would mean the world
i already told everyone to vote i want
that blimp i want oliver trees blimp
behind me that'd be fire dude dude and
some of these fans you guys could vote
anywhere between you know 50 to 100
times even more than that and all you
have to do is just finish the voting
process it spits you back out at the
beginning have you considered going like
outsourcing to like an indian click farm
or anything
of course yeah we tried that and we we
had some mild success with that we have
a couple different companies working on
it and
i'm working with a company called
meditek and meditek laboratories
actually has their own setup right right
uh i hope you win man i'm actually
curious about these other categories
favorite male creator let's see
mr beast oh ryan obviously
ryan's toy review oh yeah dude favorite
me uh female creator uh
emma for sure
uh favorite female sports star okay
so
serena
you know
favorite male sports star uh your boy
shawn white
i guess over brady damn dude i don't
know bro
favorite global music star
are you nominated in that category bts
bts i should have been on there i should
have been on this yeah
oh that's interesting they put bts at
the end to get everyone to vote a
gazillion times they were also nominated
for best group i saw like oh they were
all nominations that's right all right
so
then oh so it started all over that's
crazy it automatically started over so
you could just sit so if you can yeah
ethan if you could just do it one more
time just uh you know try to so wait for
do you remember which number you are out
of 27 so i can just remember
uh i think 26 it's 22. 22. okay so let
me just click through
whoa love says he's building a bot so
that's good
oh you know and i love this look
lovebot you're looking really good today
man actually he is i like the setup
all right what did you say 24 uh maybe
20 22 22. oh [ __ ]
who did i just vote for
dude you passed it you [ __ ] voted for
someone else are you [ __ ] kidding me
dude okay wait wait you're doing this
[ __ ] on purpose no no i'll start over
i'll start over i'll start over
you're a [ __ ] dick dude wait hold on
i'll start over
i'll go back to 22 and see
i'm sorry you promised bro no trust me i
want that blimp okay
[Music]
dude you're screwing both of us here
dude
i i'm going back man all right maybe
maybe slow down maybe my count was off
okay well i know it's in the 20s
it's in the 20s
i'll slow down when i get to 20. okay
all right let's see who did you vote for
i'll find out
all right so i think it's coming up
earlier if that person wins it was
addison ray [ __ ] pissed
no
no that's my most fierce competition
all right i'm gonna vote for you how
could you [ __ ] do that to me bro so
it's in the bottom left if you guys want
to click through like just click through
all day
oh you know what if you do so much by
the way if you do win a kids choice
award uh you'll be in really good
company uh previous kids choice awards
james charles
whoa crazy david dobrik
michael jackson wow
wait what michael had one too yeah
i know you're a big fan of his
huge
yeah these are all really good people
man drake bell actually won a uh kids
choice award
uh will smith i mean i don't know is
that is that fair to throw will there in
the in the pod right
actually harvey weinstein
harvey weinstein
he's got a bunch uh did he win
yeah he won for favorite male uh
uh creator
uh woody allen
wow roman polanski i believe yeah he won
he won two years in a row yeah uh bill
cosby won
r kelly
yeah or kelly that's right he won two
so you can be in really good company so
hopefully we're really rooting for you
here
yeah i believe thank you man hey that
means the world yeah actually um harvey
weinstein won for the biggest slime
award
wow yeah kevin spacey kevin spacey won
he won frank kavanagh
so you could be with the greats there
the hall of fame i'm gonna quit company
actually i'm gonna click through
i'm gonna keep clicking through for you
so remember you're on the bottom left so
if you guys
want to vote for uh oliver and whoever
else is in the bottom left yo that
bottom left category is gonna crush bro
hell yeah dude your guys are going to
literally get this whole entire contest
rigged bro and that's what we got to do
here we got to take down the mainstream
together oh hell yeah brother
yeah i'm pretty sure oh yeah brother
you know what's funny if if like bts is
in the bottom left for some category you
might just win by default too huh
i don't think they are
damn
let's see
i mean there's some good people in the
bottom left here we go uh oh chris brown
won kids choice award
yeah man that was a good year
yeah
so that was a really good year
so it's pretty exciting you know
walk with giants they say stand on the
shoulder of giants like r kelly
dude you have no idea how much this
means to me thank you man all right i
want that blimp you understand me i'm
going to give you that blimp i'm going
to deliver it myself to your front door
and you're going to let you know teddy
or michael or whatever his name is they
can play with that and you know the
thing is man
you can play with it you know whatever
you want it's up to you it's your blimp
so when does the voting close
it closes i think tomorrow or the next
day i don't know i think it's on
saturday so like so
we can do on friday another uh drive you
want to call in on friday and just
motivate people again i would love to
let's just do another call on friday
we'll schedule that
your guy's name is dan so when we talk
we have the dance connect
so let's let's you have my dance oh wait
no we have an interview on friday yeah i
gotta bump you oh dude don't move the
interview move the interview this is
much more important
you do you don't gotta bump [ __ ] dude
you could plug it right before the
interviewer actually during your ads you
know
the ads would be a good time to do it we
can we can plug it at the top of the
show
that would be great did you pay you know
what can i ask you a question you know
yeah did you pay to be nominated in this
i'm not supposed to talk about this but
yeah
there was some financial investment
involved i actually had the label drop
off a suitcase full of forty thousand
dollars and that's really the only
reason i got the nomination but i do
wanna say this um
you know that doesn't guarantee a win
and that's why i need your help and i
need the foot soldiers and the fupa
troopers to join together so he can get
this big w yeah are you calling in the
logan paul show next to beg his fans to
vote for you too you [ __ ] traitor
what do you mean dude no definitely not
i mean i'm i'm a fupa trooper
sounds to me like you're a maverick
hey yeah that's true represent you're
right yeah
it looks pretty damn good too it does
actually you look good in it you've been
losing weight you've been working
out uh i wouldn't say that i actually
put on a freshman 15 approximately 15 to
20 pounds sod i've been picking it up
during tour man late night pizzas and
you know all kinds of you know macaroni
and cheeses and uh you know as you can
see my belly it's been
no you look pretty big you look good
you look good dude look at you stop it
you look good man
you look good look at you you look like
a million bucks like one of those guys
that would maybe get a nomination for a
kid's choice award
all right
enough for you
all right well dude i want to thank you
so much from the bottom of my heart and
i know
you are the guy to come to whenever i
need something so thank you
we love him go vote for him it's oliver
tree we want that blimp i genuinely
think for us
vote for us this is ours
absolutely that's a good one let's vote
people
if we win we can destroy the blimp
together no no no whoa
that's my blimp you're talking about
well you you can do whatever you want i
was saying we can make a video for your
old channel when you used to make real
content okay whoa
what happened to
the nice oliver
no no no no it came off wrong yeah that
came off
your old channel i could help manage
your old channel all right don't you
don't you have music to write or some
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] go do something bro
i could help manage your old channel
bring some of my documentaries on there
and maybe we could
produce some stuff together
all right thank you oliver
all right take care buddy
enjoy that i wanted to say a couple more
things i really think this could be big
for the both of us man all right you can
you can cut them off okay no wait just
older
it's nice to talk to you
yeah
in the attic he's down bad dude he's
begging for that kid's choice jesus
22 out of 26
that was not easy to vote for him i
gotta say did not make it did not make
that an easy easy thing there
i do want that blimp though on
ironically that would be sick
you think he'd really give it to me
i know what's gonna happen if he went to
be like you serious you thought i'd give
this to you you're a [ __ ] loser
that's 100 what's going to happen
but honestly in california that does
constitute an agreement i could sue him
for the blimp and i will that's now
we're talking i will i love that i will
straight up sue him and his record
company and all and i'll sue them for
defamation tortious interference
copyright infringement
so that's ryan cavanaugh what speaking
of oliver jimmy lee just text me i guess
he's watching little jimmy yeah he's
like i look
he sent me a joke he's like i looked up
oliver's tree four dogs were using it
oh that's pretty good i looked up
oliver's tree four dogs were using it
boom roasted
not bad jimmy that's pretty good not bad
that's a joke i mean it's an actual joke
right which is progress it's mid i don't
know well give the man credit at least
it's not racist yeah exactly
i looked up oliver's i mean that could
have gone you know
man that guy oliver tree huh
kid's choice away
next thing he'll be showing up at ace
family basketball charity
[Music]
you know
idiot
oh man
you know
there's so much to talk about we never
get a real wholesome uh
uh super chat real quick hell no yeah
good i'm just kidding uh jm donated 45
british pounds and said uh hi ethan crew
i just like to say
thank you was watching families last
year i remember your mom said if you
want to marry someone you shouldn't wait
the day after i bought a ring next week
i'm proposing my girlfriend of three
years family oh
way to go jm
that's beautiful family family family
family family stop fam
wow that was like perfect
yeah we're aligned but love is back in
sweden and [ __ ] the whole thing up yeah
i'm very sad sorry about that it's okay
we get that extra love
love brings the extra he puts the uh fam
and family or the
something like that i'll work on that
playing words a little bit all right
all right i want to talk to you guys
we've got elon musk buying
nine percent of twitter god was so much
to get to but i just oh my god
i want to talk about all this stuff
so much
so much um okay let's just blast through
it because i want to do all this a
christian comedian
you know that's always powerful
oh you're gonna you're gonna crack up
christian i love all christian art forms
i love christian comedy i love christian
music i love uh
now this one hits
okay let's see oh yeah yeah i'm a
christian and i'm a comedian but i'm not
a christian comedian
i hate to break it to you lady but
that's exactly what you are i see where
this is going
i only tell jokes to praise the lord to
give
my all my jokes are pre-approved by the
church to pray all give praise to jesus
no can i get an amen not this one that's
what makes her different you're going to
see
she brings the explain
letter
let me explain
amen now i went over that let me explain
with my priest and he told
me that there ain't no devil in that
line
amen
i don't have jokes they're like so
matthew mark luke and john walk into a
bar
sinners
[ __ ] you just said that joke that is
your joke
you just you go you did the joke
and you were hoping for laughs
no she doesn't do jokes like that like
she did no but she does she did
that's part of the bit
it's not my style
and like a lot of my comic friends they
always tell me like oh you're so
conservative right and then like my
christian friends is like oh you're so
edgy
but like i just do me like what i mean
like i can't be anybody else but me
[Music]
just like jesus
just like jesus baby
just do you and do you well
oh amen like i'll tell you the truth i
love jesus okay okay shout out don't
hide it
but i will punch a hoe
[Applause]
you're gonna watch our next special wait
i thought this was longer
there's so many good jokes to make about
christianity
like you know jesus mom was a straight
[ __ ] ho
you telling me she just got gave birth
out of nowhere
like hell no dude
like i'm sorry
[Music]
i'm just saying
how many single moms be out here talking
about immac wish they could be talking
about immaculate conception
like when where's your daddy immaculate
conception man jesus mom was a whole the
only reason she talked about immaculate
concision because she didn't know who
the daddy was because there's no dna
testing back then
now that's a christian joke boy can i
get an amen
i'll tell you what i don't think that
that's a christian joke
it's about christianity right but how
many wise men were there
seven no please don't how many wise men
there was three wise men
i'll tell you what
the only reason she talked about
immaculate conception because those
three is wise men ran a train and they
didn't know who's the one that ended up
inseminating her can i get a a man amen
ain't no dna test what
i'll tell you what
how many baby mamas wish they could
admit
you say girl you sleep with him nah baby
that's immaculate conception amen
now that's material that's great some
top tier eat them pretty soon you go to
hell
i'm just saying
i'm just saying just saying
i'm just saying
come on now stop the fear three wise men
[ __ ] three drunk men oh can i get an
amen that's material amen
amen take this show on the road
i'm just saying
this is the blood of god term yeah yeah
i bet y'all i bet you have daddy turn uh
water to wine [ __ ]
see where you wind yourself up in you
see what you've done yeah my uncle used
to turn water and wine it's called
moonshine
she's an alcoholic any day no
amen
testify
ain't nothing wrong with that
you know
amen brother
i tell you what
they touch you what
amen ain't none be ashamed of boy
i don't know
i was just testing out my christian
material
no good huh
crickets
funnier than hers oh well
that may be true
again just like jimmy
the
when the bar is low
amen
can i get on i can't wait to see audio
i love that
yo people can't get mad come on
christians they'd be like christians be
like we the most we christian white men
today are the most
we are the most judged and hated people
in society
oh [ __ ] is that a black man in my
neighborhood called the swat team
amen i get a man hands up god thank you
no
no man
not aiming in that i'd take amen in that
i tell you what man i wouldn't trust no
i wouldn't trust my kids with nobody but
a christian
you say you really want to get all to
the all this uh stuff from the doc today
okay we got we got all that bad huh good
stuff
i tell you what i wouldn't trust my kids
with nobody but a christian
oh but don't tell them except on sundays
and uh oh boy and and at scout church at
church at overnights alone with the
pastor with the boy scouts any of the
choir of the choir boys any the air but
only christians amen
even the pope god damn
amen
what are we going to do
all right
thank you
ian thoughts is that ready uh that show
ready for the road or not yet
just spitballing or maybe workshop it a
little bit and you know some of the
smaller clubs for a little while there's
something there yeah
okay so this is interesting because
we've analyzed this wave pool
quite a bit and now we have a new angle
of it
it popped up for me and i was blown away
that we had never seen this so in china
there was a massive wave pool
that malfunctioned and shot this monster
rogue wave that was just
just pure chaos energy
and um
it's a hell of a it's a hell of a thing
and so
we've seen it from other angles but
apparently we have that amazing angle
where
a guy is riding on top and just slams
straight into the camera man just he's
riding one of those whales all the way
to [ __ ] valhalla bro all the way into
the
afterlife it's always known for dear
life like a damn uh nuclear torpedo sent
to uh hit the eastern seaboard
oh [ __ ] here
oh oh no
i can't believe that's a strong machine
that could just kick that up all the
time
guys never turn your back on the ocean
yeah true well let's learn to be fair
i don't think they could have escaped
that now is anybody seriously hurt in
that or maybe let's not even look into
it
i think we did nobody died right nobody
died
let's not investigate any further
[Music]
jesus bro
oh my god
[ __ ]
yeah he go man good times
there it is
praise jesus
elon musk about nine percent of twitter
he's a [ __ ]
i don't know what
this is what the man he
who cares elon musk's boring me i i
can't be on twitter anymore twitter i've
realized is the mind killer twitter is
sap is the
sapper of joy
it is the ruiner of life twitter is
truly i think
needs to and should go the way of
facebook soon
twitter needs to die it's just a scourge
on this earth hey twitter and it's not
real life and i just i'm realizing more
and more how much i hate
and think twitter is bad
and elon musk buying nine percent of it
because he thinks it's basically the
he thinks it's
the most important
he thinks
my god
if uh
if charlie kirk
can't post himself doing a uh
nazi salute on twitter then all is lost
he probably could do that actually
yeah and that would probably fly
it my god if uh
if charlie kirk can't uh
uh
what do you even get banned for on
twitter these days except like explicit
uh
coven misinfo
you know well elon was pretty upset
about that so
that might be part of the motivation
elon musk's dropped three billion
dollars to buy nine percent of twitter
because he's angry that uh
it's anti-free speech
he says free speech is essential to
functioning democracy
do you believe twitter rigorously
adheres to this principle
talk about bias i was like of course the
people following you are going to vote
no
but who cares
you know people go billionaires can't
pay taxes
don't you don't understand bro it's all
tied up in stock it's like they don't
even have liquid meanwhile elon musk
drops 3 billion dollars just for a meme
to buy ten percent of [ __ ] twitter
um
bro you telling me you can't pay taxes
you just got three billion dollars
laying around for a gag
so now elon musk is on the twitter board
oh if it's a gag i don't i don't think
he's doing it for the meme
you think he really wants to have a
stake in controlling uh public opinion
and stuff and and yeah and just dip into
i mean this is
a pretty common thing with uh you know
the ultra rich is they get involved in
the media sphere i mean almost all of
the media in this company is owned by a
set of a handful of ultra rich and well
uh you know i think this is
to him he's obsessed with twitter uh you
know he's on it pretty much all day uh
i don't understand how he runs like 10
companies when with the amount of [ __ ]
posting that he does on twitter um
and yeah i think you know in his
world view it's it's the most important
one because it's the one that that he's
obsessed with
and yeah i think he's he wants a stake
in it so that he can um you know kind of
bend things to
his will
well jeff bezos owns the washington post
um rupert murdoch
owns like everything every
[ __ ] piece of media that exists so i
mean yeah twitter is is a major it is a
major uh media source
for sure
yeah and then it's just kind of weird
how people have this cognitive
dissonance where they don't realize that
having the richest man alive owning
a majority slice of a media company is
not good
yeah and especially when he's doing it
under the auspices of oh you know free
speech is
important to uh rigorous democracy i i
i would
argue that the sort of concentration of
wealth that elon musk has
is a bigger threat to democracy than um
you know nazis and pedophiles getting
banned off of social media
that
that's just me but that seems like a
bigger threat to actual democracy than
uh
yeah than trump getting booted off
oh yeah definitely
uh twitter shares surged 27 well no [ __ ]
he injected three billion dollars
right
uh
well and i think
it you know he had been uh
i don't know there's like weirdness with
it too because he had been spending like
the last month
talking [ __ ] about how horrible twitter
is and how he needs to start his own
social media company and blah blah blah
blah and then next thing you know
he buys the largest stake
in
twitter um
so maybe it was just a matter of
a reversal of
you know the public perception of
twitter's future
like the fact that he's buying it gives
people more faith that twitter is gonna
be a money maker which i i really don't
think it is no we'll never make twitter
makes money i think they they lose money
twitter will never make money i mean
yeah but
you know and it is ironic because elon
musk talks about being a free speech you
know
absolutist yeah twitter is a private
company right so obviously
free speech has nothing to do with
private it's about the government
censoring what at least in terms of yeah
first amendment yeah that has
but so like if he has a problem with how
twitter is is quote censoring people
then why
is elon musk he's firing tesla employees
for posting a youtube review of tesla's
autopilot function
he's a doxxed an anonymous blogger who
posted a negative stock analysis of
tesla
and contacted their employer threatening
to sue he did that
[Music]
he really did that
evidently
elon musk allegedly silenced an online
critic with peter thiel's playbook
i'm not gonna oh it's not that long
have you read this article dan yeah
yeah this uh there was a recent article
um
that kind of compiled all of this um and
they
were kind enough to uh
to link to all of the original sources
which i gotta say
other uh
more mainstream like an insider is
really good about this when when they're
like referring to other reporting they
actually link the article new york times
and washington post like never [ __ ]
do that and it's really annoying they
just refer to
reporting has suggested that blah blah
blah has happened or whatever howard's
let me see the [ __ ] report then yeah
coward oh i i really i do appreciate
that they actually embed links and you
know allow you to kind of read into it
yourself
uh he's personally canceled the
canceled the order of a model x of a
journalist who uh was critical of their
launch event
he's fired employees for disagreeing
with him he's fired employees for
reporting racist harassment he's he's
fired employees for simply getting in
his way
um so in his own private company he
doesn't seem to value free speech
absolute uh which you know absolutism
but on twitter he seems by all means man
it's your [ __ ] company you can fire
people if you want to uh
you know
not that those firings are justified but
it's like that's the point like it's
your company you can control who works
there
twitter is a social media platform
they're allowed to control who
participates in it it's not the [ __ ]
government it's not the public square
uh it's just it's just such a bunk
argument
dude i feel like conservatives love elon
now
he's become like a darling kind of like
joe rogan has
and
it's just so ironic how easy they are to
get got because they always talk about
like coastal elites
and big media and all this [ __ ] is like
the enemy of the people right and look
at you [ __ ] suckers elon musk the
richest man in the world has just
consolidated his power buying a huge
chunk of twitter and y'all [ __ ] love
it you don't you see what suckers and
losers and [ __ ] yoga guys it just got
tooken by elon musk bro
he doesn't care about you see i don't
think that they really care either i
don't think it's ever about consistency
it's just about it's just about owning
somebody you know it's about owning the
other side and i don't even think like i
mean you know by no means is uh
elon uh you know left wing um
but
i i don't think he's you know i don't
think he's an extremist i don't think
he's a q anon dude or anything like that
but um
i think oh he's definitely a like fiscal
conservative oh yeah for sure yeah he
doesn't he doesn't want to [ __ ]
help anybody right
but
um
well you know anyway elon really on
twitter he just he shitposts nonstop
he steals memes from around the internet
really horrible memes too the worst and
people think it's i guess i don't know
why people like it because if anyone
else did it would be embarrassing so we
took it upon ourselves we took on this
project we said okay elon musk is
stealing
horrible shit-tier [ __ ] grandma dog
[ __ ] memes
and we want to figure out where is he
getting these means from by the way he
never credits anyone
yeah
um and people love it so we've done our
own investigation here so here's one
elon musk posted netflix waiting for the
war to end to make a movie about a black
ukraine guy fall in love with the
transgender russian soldier i mean this
is like such edge lord pleb comedy
so where did and then you know 750 000
likes he's literally just ripping off
shitty memes so where does he find this
let's see
yeah
ifunny.com
yeah and so these won't be definitive
this is what we did is we did reverse
engine uh image searches on a few
image reverse like not just google but
like there's a few other third party
ones um
and just tried to find the oldest
version of these memes um so we can't
say with a hundred percent certainty
that this was where
uh he got it from but these are where
they're at least first appearing on the
internet places like ifunny and as
you'll see uh some other top tier dude
the dude ripped a meme from ifunny.co
and posted it on twitter now
this is
this is not this is this is cringe it's
great not funny
wait till you see some of the other
sources i mean it doesn't get much worse
than ifunny.com but okay
i support the current thing more
edgelord posting by elon musk
and again like the meme is in pretty
poor taste considering like there's a
straight up uh
[ __ ]
civilian holocaust going on in the
ukraine right now
yeah just ukraine
i gotta correct you on that it's just
ukraine not the ukraine
you said it before and people got mad
and so i'm gonna okay thank you don't
get mad at me
you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you i'm mad at
you [ __ ] ukraine
can y'all just stop being mad at
everything
that one that one
i don't if you're trying to be sensitive
to the war that's going on the the the
is what
people in russia call it because it they
think of it as a region of russia not as
its own country whereas ukraine exactly
there you go i support the current thing
uh where did this come from nine gag
epic
i didn't even know 9gag was still a
thing
me neither apparently but here's elon
musk um
he's ripping off
memes from nine gag
so there you have it
our king [ __ ] poster
next one little do they know birds
aren't real
okay birds aren't real wake up people
let's see where did elon musk steal this
meme from
meme.com literally meme.com the man
i didn't even know that was the thing
uncredited ripping from meme.com it's
awesome
now it could be that somebody sent it to
him or whatever but it still gives you a
sense of uh
you know
the kind of kind of stuff that that
tickles him
kind of quality content
so there you have it i mean that's the
point is if i was doing that people
would roast me into oblivion like you're
stealing nice [ __ ] stealing memes
from my nine gag
this guy got so caught up in thinking
he's a meme lord he bought 10 of twitter
so there you have it
god forbid post memes courtney reed said
um
courtney why don't you go [ __ ]
jump in a hole hold on and disappear
forever hold on okay guys
next
die die die
i'm sorry you all don't find it cringe
that this dude's stealing memes from
nine gag oh most people do i don't know
come on now
the man could do whatever the [ __ ] he
wants but just saying just saying just
saying that's all he does
so there you go that's that okay elon
musk thank you thank you
um
[Applause]
uh oliver tree the grammys
james charles more james charles this
[ __ ] was at the grammys bro who
is inviting this guy
who is inviting him
who invited you
so
i've seen i wasn't able to confirm this
maybe somebody in the audience
knows
maybe people in the audience
know how this works
there there's been a lot of people on
twitter saying he paid
to to appear on the red carpet yeah well
he wasn't actually invited but you can
like pay money to like walk the red
carpet and have your picture taken and
then they just ask why you know
if o.j simpson said hey can i pay you to
be there you know they probably wouldn't
take his money
but i think that's pretty [ __ ] funny
if he paid to fake being at the grammys
that is funny someone said he bought a
ticket so you can just buy a ticket and
act like you're invited i i don't think
that you you can't just buy a tick you
can buy a ticket to like the the
bleachers at the red carpet like where
all like the and then you get like
for the celebrities and everything i
don't think that ticket gets you the
ability to walk around on the red carpet
but
but maybe maybe maybe it does but that
that explanation makes a lot more sense
to me than him being invited well that
is funny then but you can walk the red
carpet and get the photo like you're
there yeah and which maybe we should do
that yeah
we should totally do that
it's pretty incredible if that's what
happened and he's just trying to be like
yo
good vip as [ __ ]
you can't keep getting away with oh
somebody said he actually won a grammy
for the womp womp song
and coming and the winner is
[Music]
[Laughter]
well that's fair
hit us with the yeah yeah dan it's been
a while
keep keep playing it i need to get the
groove
[Music]
i think you need to win a grammy
[Music]
can i get a taste
look at those mommy milkers
don't move ethan don't move
[Music]
yeah anyway the title is how is james
charles ev everywhere other than prison
true man
right on baby
right on
[Music]
uh
yeah
louie so louis ck also apparently won an
award for best comedy album
the world is just so weird right now
that's kind of the theme of this section
that we put together is like the grammys
apparently are just the place for all
the feel like cancelled people to
be honored
although best comedy album i don't think
the competition is very stiff in that
category
yeah who makes comedy albums i guess
probably not many
uh so
congratulations to louis ck
he won for his most recent special
sincerely louis ck here's my dick
weird title
whoa the award was announced at a
ceremony before his official telecast
the recording academy also made the
announcement on its twitter account by
showing a picture of louis ck in a robe
exposing his genitals weird why would he
really embracing it
at least he's embracing it right
like louis ck's cover of his comedy
album should just be him in a robe like
this hide my [ __ ] dick actually his
next coming up special is called
uh would you watch me jack off oh
apparently he won over bo burnham that's
oh that's gotta hurt that sucks bo borbo
that sucks he's like i didn't even jerk
off was it was it an album of of that
inside special because that thing was
amazing like i haven't heard the louis
one but i i have to imagine the boat i
don't know it's been a while since that
movie came out
yeah i'm not sure
wow he really won over bo that's [ __ ]
has louis ever even made jokes about the
jerking off in front of people thing
oh my mom
she issued a correction she said
i'm 67 this year i don't know why i said
50s that was way off i was not about to
correct you because that is a really
rude thing to say but when you said that
i was like how was your mom no no
baby no
i don't know where that came from it's
like your parents are this specific age
in your mind from when you were
right and a teenager walks in yeah yeah
no no not 55.
kanye west won
two grammys despite being banned
from entering yeah i wouldn't let him in
the building but they would honor him
let's see he kanye west won two grammys
and broke the record for the most
wins for a hip-hop artist despite being
pulled from the show over his concerning
online behavior
thoughts ian
did deserve did he deserve the award ian
what are you afraid of ian
that's crazy man
do you think that he genuinely who is he
up against like was it was it the best
album regardless of his yes
i don't know who else was nominated i'm
not sure um it was best uh
just best friend
best rap song i will say i wasn't crazy
about that song no
it was hurricane his song with the
weeknd was awarded best melodic rap
performance that seems very niche it's
like just make up your mind is it
melodic what do we how many uh
very granular with certain things but
then extremely broad with others uh and
yeah i don't
i mean
yeah melodic rap i guess you know it's
rap that has more singing and more of
like an r b influence versus i get it
but
um gotta kind of just pick a lane almost
like the kids choice awards yeah i mean
how many categories i've always found it
and i apologize ahead of time to any
metalheads in the audience but
best metal album has its own category
but it's like
there's tons of sub genres
you know there's infinite sub genres of
rock music why
specifically metal has its own category
and then just all other rock music is
another one i i don't the grammys are
just weird
best melodic rap best beat
best singing on a rap album best tap
dancing on a rap album
best backup vocals on a rap album that's
yodeling on a rap album
best single verse on a rap album
um
okay also jared leto was there who's
actually faced a string of accusations
that he prays on young girls but i don't
think anyone needed that to be told that
to know that that that man actually and
the interesting thing is jared leto
presented an award for best new artist
to olivia rodrigo
rudd
rodrigo is it rodri rodrigo yeah oh
there's a typo here yeah rodrigo okay
who is
17 or 18
oh serving up she's 19. she's 19. oh
she's 19.
so like
youngest too young to be in proximity of
jerry exactly let's find the youngest
pop star
and have jared leto present the word to
her
you left me in a black hole of rage and
confusion
[Laughter]
yeah rumors are circulating that he just
basically texts
young fans non-stop
some fans seem concerned that he was
invited to present awards in the first
place with what many
there's been many uh allegations against
him recently
the actor has been hit with several
controversies over past allegations with
the focus on targeting underage girls
via text messages
they're like okay perfect let's find the
youngest women uh pop star
and pat and and match them up with uh
jared leto
this was for is the new york post like a
tabloid or is this oh yeah so
i guess take it
the grain of salt but definitely a
tabloid but i mean there's a lot out
there about him i mean we did a whole
[ __ ] content court where we did the
deep dive on his literal [ __ ] sex
cult that he runs yeah i can freak would
you die for me
girls from img elite and next and women
are staying there and jared has been
hitting on all of them he's a serial
texter he is constantly texting these 16
and 17 year old girls it's creepy when i
was 16 jared leto asked my friend also
14 to come up to his hotel room
and then dylan sprouse actually really
famously
uh publicly called him out yo jared now
that you've slid into the gyms every
female model age 18 to 25 what would you
say your success rate is
i mean we could really be dealing with a
really bad situation where people are
just letting them slide
someone's got a [ __ ]
typical [ __ ] you know
typical uh hollywood [ __ ]
you'll be like we never saw it
coming we never suspected that jared
leto was a creep
jared leto
colt
look at this [ __ ] we nev we never saw it
coming
you guys
who could have seen us coming
we had no idea he was texting young
girls
jared leto's a creep
how old is this girl here
like genuinely that girl is
18 at most
look how young these girls are do you
see a single man in the audience here
[Music]
do you see a single man
except for him
i do not this is not normal behavior
i need a machine gun guys we need
how many times are we gonna do this
and i think it gets a pass because uh or
not a pass but like uh
he gets more leeway because he's
well really handsome and he looks
relatively young do you know how old
jared leto is i shocked me he's in his
50s he's 50 years old yeah no it shocked
me too he i mean he takes great care of
himself don't get me wrong
you know
he's a 50 year old man maybe you know
maybe this is a sex cult with a bunch of
teenagers maybe the secret to uh aging
gracefully is just having sex with a
bunch of 16 year olds god
that was epstein's theory actually
how old was epstein when he died
i don't know
epstein was obsessed with like uh
anti-aging stuff though you know how old
is that
i know
66
oh he looked good
interesting he's on that jared leto diet
oh god
or maybe jared let's on the epstein diet
we couldn't we we didn't see who could
have seen this coming right jared leto
he was so and he was he was such a
normal guy
presenting to olivia rodrigo
for
for
yeah of all the youngest female pop star
god jared has gone forward james gunn
called him out as well
oh what did james gunn said uh he
responded to dylan sprouse's tweet and
he said he starts at 18 on the internet
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah oh wow she now did
yeah so you know and these are big time
people so that's
then that's not something you tweet out
unless you know some [ __ ]
james gunn's a huge deal that's crazy
we could never have known
dude you can't even spots well okay
here's a here's a few moms here
chaperones probably because their
daughters are underage i hope so
unironically i hope that they're
chaperoning
well yeah otherwise how you can get a 13
year old to come on a retreat with jared
leto
i mean my god
he just seems so normal he took all of
our daughters out on a camping trip but
was just so nice he just loves youth he
just wants to shape and crack he just
wants to educate and crap he's so
holistic he's just such a good guy that
jared leto
oh my god he was so normal
guys
guys who's got a sound is coming
dude
who would have seen this who could have
seen it
it's like jonestown
straight up past about to pass that
kool-aid around you know what's in that
kool-aid don't kill you just make you
pass out for 20 minutes and i am not
suicidal you know what i'm saying
i do i am not suicide
who's that j who is that
yeah don't worry jessica nobody's
worried
one way or the other
he was just such a good guy
this comes as a shock to all of us
look at that we're just so shocked to
find out what jared leto's been up to
[Music]
be a documentary in 20 years we just had
no idea
his producer his manager his best friend
we just had no idea
he just seemed like such a good guy
i'm watching this documentary about uh
jimmy savile
on netflix came out really good huh
uh and you know a lot of it's just like
we had no idea
is that the weirdest creepiest [ __ ]
dude that ever lived
that man jimmy seville i don't know how
he went under the radar
but if just a look at the guy
this dude
yeah we had no idea
he was [ __ ] dude this man is [ __ ]
twisted bro
really good documentary on netflix i
didn't know that they made one about it
it just came out it just came out it's
really good
we had no idea
my god
what's going on with the name jared
jared yeah bad bad rap
jared
jared leto jared from gary vogel
yeah
pro pro jarrod
oh
what's going on with jared's dude
somebody named a good jerry quick i know
he's right no one good jared you do zach
your brother's name's jared yeah brother
keep an eye on that one man he's a good
guy he's great
yeah all right
i need a background check great heart
great feet great feet oh we know that he
has good feet he's hard working that's
c-man approved pretty good feet i give
him a beat
you know kind of hot i guess i don't
know pretty hot you know toe polish i
like them a little more tan
yeah you know i like having fun with
guys and blowing loads on feet i guess i
don't know
we gotta check in on c-man
yeah it's been a while
also i want to check in on the
fleshlight guy you guys get it because
he made that new skippy
peanut butter one oh yeah let me check
on the fleshlight guy okay
any update from jimmy
lee
is he working on material zach or uh i
mean he's been texting me like
all the time
but nothing about
new material he's kind of been sending
me the same picture like every day
um
all right well jimmy i hope you're
working if you're literally well you
sent that all over tree joke that was
right that was you know and then fairly
solid we sent him a picture that meme
that cam made and he he called me right
before the show and he's like can i get
sued for this
and i'm like no jimmy you can't get sued
for that
is he is are you guys still negotiating
the terms of you working with him or no
i'm i was gonna call him or speak with
him about that later on
um but
our plan is to have a redemption with
him when he comes back out here in may
zach's still trying to
figure out an angle where he can get all
of this with the rolex yeah yeah yeah i
think that's fair yeah i do
i really do
if you've got to spend that much time
with the man he owes you a rolex the
torture
i mean
no offense jimmy but it's a lot it's a
lot
your time is valuable you're you're
you're
he's a busy guy
he's a funny guy you're a busy guy
i just he it cannot be with his crew
this time it has to be us
has to be
you're his mic is quiet for me dan i
can't really hear zach i don't know if
he's talking quiet how about now can you
hear me now so better yeah i can hear
you now okay
anyway here's an album of the big
winners from the grammys they've been
they've just been giving out awards to
anybody these days vladimir putin won
the best humanitarian
wow for his second win for his work in
ukraine liberating right ukraine is the
follow-up to it from his uh 2014 smash
hit uh
crimea invasion yeah
invasion you mean liberating oh i'm
sorry right yeah freedom for crimea the
liberation of crimea so congratulations
vladimir putin vladimir putin jim jones
best gospel album
i don't know what's the deal with jim
reverend jim jones
jonestown you just referenced it a few
minutes ago with uh kool-aid don't drink
the coffee don't drink the kool-aid he's
the cool egg he's the cooler man man oh
yeah well i've heard his music is very
good
yeah and you know it was a church so
yeah it's some christian music
um
we have of course jeffrey dahmer
best cooking instructional album wow and
the i mean give it up because he does
have a very unique experience
um
the man has kind of
he has more experience in the kitchen
than almost anyone else
it's a uh
interesting palette he has sure of
course and that you know that's
everything um king kim jong-un for best
global music album
look at him he's so happy it's finally
his time
i gotta say that man has the
weirdest shaped head i've ever seen in
my life it's odd
he really just
and the haircut he he plays it up good
man the dude is like i want
he's like shape my head like an upside
down
lego piece
[Music]
say no more i mean the man his face is a
block it's just a block of flesh
so shout out
to my boy kim jong-un
best global music album
that's that's that that's not a joke
actually louis ck won best comedy album
that's that's actually happened
whoa
yeah i got i got some
breaking news here
sure
uh i mean it's related to all of this go
ahead
drake bell
his real name is jared
oh no
no wonder he changed it to drake but you
can't escape the jared
guys name me a good jared quick holy
[ __ ] we have to break this
thank you for pointing that out uh avery
we need a real jared
quickly
jared uh kushner
no
[ __ ] that guy's a demon in human skin
um did you guys know that lee harvey
oswald won best country album
and then r kelly actually lifetime
achievement award yep
the man has had a long uh long career
yep
beautiful voice
so they have eventful night the emmys
so shout out to all the lovely winners
wow colorful characters louis ck
redemption
oh
oh that one's real
that one is real that that one's
actually real
yeah
this one's not a joke at all which is
interesting right
[Laughter]
you guys think it's a joke
yeah no
jared kushner is such a creep bro
he's like slender man
in real life
he's just this guy
he's got slenderman energy for sure he's
just a tall pasty psycho freak he sucks
blood oh thank you thank you somebody in
the chat
uh english actor jared harris everyone
like him i do like i love i like him
guarantee he's got skeletons in the
closet though with that name ali is
english so
he was good in uh chernobyl
oh he's so good in that oh my god he's
so good i love him no i'm not i can't
even slam i can't even joke lee slander
him yeah oh he rocks wait he played the
scientist dude
yeah yeah main character that was a very
good show wow i missed that show it was
such a good show
okay we found a jared we like
shout outs
holding it down for jared's everywhere
so my brother doesn't suffice or it has
to be like i don't know you just don't
know anything about your brother other
than that he's got hot feet no your
brother he's a good dude you can take my
word for it okay well i'll take your
word yeah i'll take your word for it
thank you thank you take your word for
it
uh
okay now we come to my favorite part of
the show cav cav ryan kavanagh
see it's too late in the show this
deserves to be at the top this is too
good
how long we've been going anyway
uh we have been going for two hours
too much wine almost on the dot
oh but friday we have an interview
that's okay to i mean two hours i should
probably wrap it up because either needs
my help at home
okay well we could save it it is
evergreen um
okay well this one we can do real fast
kim kardashian apologize for get your
ass up and work so have you guys changed
your opinion on this now that she's gone
on an apology tour or do you still think
that this was engineered in a laboratory
to make people angry
love don't answer that
no answer that answer that
well i never said i knew for a fact i
said there's a possibility and i stand
by that yes and yeah what he said
get your [ __ ] ass up just say what
you want a b who cares what people think
no i was just kidding i'm not serious
okay so what do you think
no that's my opinion the same as love i
was never saying it was a certainty but
definitely a possibility and i was never
saying that they never fake anything by
the way either people [ __ ] go crazy
dude they were saying i mean of course
some stuff is engineered i don't think
this was
damn it
damn you made
women in business
and it got a lot of backlash it did and
saying
you know go to work get up and go to
work
what did you mean by that and what do
you want to say now about it
well that
statement that i said was without
questions and conversation around it and
it became a sound bite really with no
context boring
shut up nobody cares bye [ __ ] well that
in itself is a good sound bite because i
feel like we could use that for a lot of
[ __ ]
i know you meant what you said
nobody wants to work
are you saying i should listen to it
because there's a good sound bite zach
no i'm just saying that what she said we
could use out of context to be a good
soundbite
say what
all right so like let's say like like
dan said something ridiculous and i
could just like i would like oh that's a
sound bite and it'd be like it became a
sound what a dancer no context he's
giving you just a scenario
[Laughter]
let's see people are arguing about it i
don't care this is the twitter [ __ ] like
i'm just so over twitter [ __ ] i scroll
twitter i think it's good people arguing
and i says
i just [ __ ] you all i miss not caring
about things you know
take a break remember how blissful you
used to be as a kid you're like the
world is ending iraq nuclear weapons and
masses and then you're like i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm on my bike
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
911 you're like [ __ ] this
you're on your bmx you're like i don't
give a [ __ ]
that one was a little traumatic
i mean i didn't understand the gravity
as well i was in l.a i was like i was in
new york i'm sure would have hit me
harder i was young i was a young kid i
know you well you were older than me
well we're the same age at thought no
you're two years older than me
i mean practically i'm just making a
joke don't [ __ ] do don't do the math
and be like ethan was actually 17 you
should have cared
[Laughter]
whatever you guys are doing bro
everybody's chanting cav cap the chat is
just full you guys want cav cavs they
want capcom brian kavanagh the people
demanded
if you are watching ryan kavanagh the
people demand the cav cav
content
cav cav cav cap
cav
cav
watching at home being like ethan you
better get your ass home right now
look at people want cat cav
ryan cavanaugh is a piece of [ __ ]
his app sucks brian kavanagh is the
force of nature which i urge you guys
all to leave truthful reviews on by the
way
between one and five stars truthful
reviews only use the app try it leave a
review of your experience
ain't nothing wrong with that no a judge
said so yeah literally won that lawsuit
literally
actually in the process of of about to
sue him for attorney's fees let's
go so
do you maybe want to open trailer and
read some of the recent ones you could
take a peek yeah
let's go does anyone use triller what
was that do we have that uh
charlie demilia tweets about her being
like i was posting to the wrong account
where is that oh
you know what no
you want grab
yeah we got it oh that was fast thank
you ian
these just
uh charlie
demilio
posted this on april 5th
she goes i just realized i've been
posting trailers to a random triller
account instead of my actual account
that's how many [ __ ] people there are
on that app she's like oh i only got 200
likes that's normal on trailer because
ain't nobody there it's literally a
[ __ ] ghost town over there
should retweet that from the podcast
please do man you're on it right
yeah you're logged in just hit it
oh yeah should i quote tweet or just
retweet yeah just retweet it just read
tweets yeah
yeah i mean facts preach girl and she's
being paid by them
and that's the kind of love she shows
what a dog [ __ ] app bro
oh that's great
the whole point you know ryan let me
explain what social media means it means
people need to be on it
that's the social part in media
if there's nobody there
it's not a social media it's just media
i got media on my phone just pictures
are people going to rate that oh i like
ethan's pictures there's got to be other
people on it
one star
in my opinion
right
right
thank you
so uh ryan kavanagh is out in some new
drip by the way
ryan cavanaugh he post did they post
this to his where was this post from
does anyone know who posted this
i'm not sure exactly i think it was
ryan's instagram story but i could be
mistaken
nice [ __ ] uh lighting dude all right
first thing i want to notice he's with
bryce hall he's hanging out with bryce a
lot i wonder if bryce is [ __ ] his
wife
like genuinely
you might be into that
i mean i know he's into it i just don't
know if bryce is into it ryan cuckinoff
mm-hmm
look how big the bowl is though man
probably plows the [ __ ] out of her dude
yo brad [ __ ] rails her hard
[Music]
wait now play rice gums laugh
play race comes laugh
brad the bull
oh [ __ ] you got the whole farm out there
he's into some weird kinky [ __ ] oh no
that's uh ryan's ex-wife that's the
noise
she gets sprayed by the bowl
now play some chicken sounds
you got the whole farm in there bud
uh yeah ryan's the chicken just picking
up pecking the leftovers
cleaning up the floor and [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying
now now give me the whole farm sound
this is what sex sounds like in ryan
kavanaugh's
[Applause]
oh bedroom a cow
oh [ __ ] bro he's into some weird old
[ __ ] boy you know it
already
this is the worst thing
all right anyway first thing i want to
analyze here is the feet work now now
what the [ __ ]
i don't know
now what the [ __ ] is this man doing
bro chicken foot dude
what is this posture what does the beta
alpha
uh
pickup artist say about his body
language
you know what i mean
where's the straight line it's all over
the place
look at that beta footwork never be a
beta is he trying to stand up taller or
is he drunk or he looks like he's
suspended by wires like he's like a
marionette puppet
[Laughter]
yeah i think brad's holding the wire
look how brad's standing it's you know i
bet you he's wearing a [ __ ] cage right
now
and then he's wearing like a baby blue
full hoodies get up
oh look at that
[Music]
oh there you go
he's in geppetto's workshop
ryan dreams of one day being a real boy
he doesn't feel human emotions it's a
dream of his to
feel something
he hopes that by watching brad rail his
wife he'll feel something someday
but not yet
yeah it looks like it looks like they're
holding them up like weekend at bernie's
[Laughter]
so
this was after they ran train on his
wife
and he watched that's why he's so happy
oh man he's such a weirdo
and um
we have more photos
wait we have more photos
yeah i just saw this on reddit oh the
new one
looks like yeah just bryce and ryan
sitting down together at dinner
quality time my man
my man
i feel bad for bryce he doesn't know
he's eating with the uh trailer swindler
right there
i've kind of wonder if i should hit up
bryce and be like you know like
you know this guy's gonna like rip you
off or something right
oh they're in miami
trailer my man my boy
so anyway that's not why i'm here i'm
just buttering you guys up
uh ryan wrote a article an op-ed
on
yahoo finance
ryan kavanagh wikipedia has become
anti-democratic
what's next you're going to buy 10 of
that loser
yeah you wish you're broke though
by ryan kavanaugh man can you use a new
photo [ __ ] bro when was this photo taken
um before we read this let me just do a
seo check
rank kavanagh
number two okay good it's holding good
click that spend some time is there
anything new on the website love
no just the old classic
good stuff yeah spend some time around
here click around
open it
yeah if you have a website
like this brian cavanaugh is the force
of nature right oh wow what were you
saying love
i was just saying if you you happen to
have a website laying around
throw a link on there to our website
yes so so that your audience can
right can learn about purely so the
audience can find that website yeah
write a little bit about our website you
know all that good stuff yeah yeah
that's all
yeah
just saying
just saying just saying so anyway i'm
gonna read you this because it's [ __ ]
incredible this uh wick this whole op-ed
we've actually contacted yahoo because i
want to do a response to it
i assume this is just like a paid thing
where you can pay
so far they haven't responded so
if anyone at
yahoo finance uh
can get us in i want to write a dueling
op-ed
i think it's only fair
you know
so the dream of wikipedia was noble ryan
cavanaugh writes
instead of creating another print
encyclopedia assembled by a small group
of elites
with guilt-edged credentials
that was out of date by the time it was
published
wikipedia would be online and instantly
updated as new knowledge came to light
it would include input from credential
academics but also from self-made
experts
single subject enthusiasts who had
become
authorities on narrow topics it would be
a
democracy of knowledge what happened
what happened to this beautiful dream
the dream of wikipedia
it was understood that wikipedia's uh
infancy could be problematic
with such open access anyone could
insert incorrect information into an
entry
a danger that never existed in the
encyclopedia britannica bro has
literally gone back 10 years it's like
yeah dude everyone knows that like you
can change wikipedia i don't think that
was ever the dream
one of the earliest highest profile
examples came only five years after
wikipedia's launch in 2008 when late
night comedian stephen colbert edited
his own entry during his show that
encouraged his viewers to insert and
correct information into the entries for
george washington and elephants
wikipedia's truth squatters its citizen
editors moved to staunch the damage by
locking down entries and showing what
colbert had done but the weakness had
been exposed
so according to uh kavanaugh before this
nobody had ever
edited a wikipedia page
uh the ultimate utopia hope for
wikipedia was built on two key ideas
whatever blah blah blah you know the man
is editing and curating his own
wikipedia page
like
instead wikipedia has become an
exclusive club the vips hang out in a
lounge overlooking the dance floor
telling the dj what to play you're
outside in line behind a velvet rope you
might get a foot in the door until the
bouncer doesn't like the look of you and
chucks you out you might slip your way
past the bouncer if he's distracted and
get a couple of dances in until security
finds out and erases you conversely you
might pay a guy who knows the bouncer to
get in bro you are literally talking
about editing your own wikipedia page
you're trying to say that wikipedia as a
whole has this huge problem because you
can't edit your own page which by the
way is a violation of the site's rules
you [ __ ]
weirdo you're literally writing this
wikipedia has never been thought of as
an exclusive vip club nobody gives a
[ __ ] about their wikipedia page except
you dude
who is the vip the editors who gain more
and more access
uh they are ranked on multiple levels
from registered users to admin users
they count they
they carry alternative titles such as
most perfect
num and grand high tone vicarous which
tells you the editors see themselves
less like august guardians of the
world's knowledge and more like the
masters of a fantasy realm they have
they created bro do you
have you ever like got involved in any
page but your own many top editors can
be sure carry vast knowledge and a
commitment to getting it right but there
are simply too many with too much time
on their hands and an axe to grind
the editing nightmare begins if you see
something wrong about you on wikipedia
you'd want to get into the entry and
change it boom you can't edit your own
page
you know i think even
i think you might be able to even
as long as you disclose
the fact that you are the person because
when i remember
yeah or
to at least to some degree but i know
what he got
popped on because i remember when we
were looking into the whole like
behind-the-scenes investigation into it
is that he wasn't
he wasn't identifying he had eight sock
puppets well and then that and then he
was threatening
right that's what got him ultimately
banned yes
which by the way he doesn't mention in
this article
that he got banned no no mention of yeah
and that he had eight sock puppets
so okay you see a little something about
yourself you want to change it right but
you can't unless you have some form of
credentials even if you do enter make
the change that's the beginning of the
process not the end
wow it sounds like they really care
about uh having factual information on
there doesn't it
this change starts a conversation many
editors may now enter competing voices
may seek to prove what was wrong about
you is actually right and offer what
they believe is proof they will rebut
you with proof source material would be
debated and disputed now another group
of editors may enter the conversation
editors who have been paid to dislike
you [ __ ] you know so much about
paying editors
this is not always forbidden paid
editors must disclose that they are paid
but not all do it will become you versus
editors who are paid to outlast you you
must counter by paying a more senior
editor to fix the damage or more likely
you realize you have a job and a family
and you give up
that's not what happened you didn't
realize that you haven't gotten a family
you got banned you fought to the bitter
end until you got banned
yeah you didn't quit because you have a
family and a [ __ ] kid you you
actually got banned this war of
attrition process has been uh attested
to by wikipedia trustee uh whatever the
[ __ ] tiring out once opponent is a
common strategy among experienced
wikipedians i have resorted to it many
times
ryan kavanaugh's age wikipedia can't
decide
oh that's the problem
wikipedia is paint itself bro it's he
says look but now wikipedia can't even
decide if i was born in 1974 or 1975.
holy [ __ ] this whole website's [ __ ]
pretty incredible that he actually wrote
this
so he does they can't tell what year i
was born
um
apparently he mentions me at the end
this shit's pretty boring actually
i put uh i put the choice quotes uh in
the dock if you want to just oh great
skip to the yeah to the
juice when an entry is systematically
attacked into face by people with
nothing but time on their hands
dude you're the one with eight sock
puppets yeah
he's talking about himself there who are
willing to and able to outlast the
effort of those who seek to repair the
damage this game over
let's say someone has sued you
citing a false and fantastical claim
you stole a lion from a zoo there is no
law against frivolous lawsuits and they
are cheap to file wow i wonder how you
know that
[Music]
he knows a lot about that
by the way he's wrong you have if you if
you say like oh he
if you say in the wikipedia oh he was
accused
he was sued for stealing a zoo the you
you need to give context right it needs
to be like it's pending there's no
evidence to support it
if a reporter from one of wikipedia's
reliable source publication writes that
you've been sued for stealing a line
from a zoo because journalists are drawn
to uh salacious allegations a wikipedia
editor may include the article in your
entry when the court dismisses the
frivolous lawsuit because you in fact
did not steal a line from the zoo
wikipedia will not correct the record of
your entry unless the court action
proving you are innocent is written
about in one of the wikipedia's reliable
sources
yeah so i looked into that that is
100 not true and uh you can look at the
policy right there you absolutely can
sort source a uh legal materials yeah it
doesn't need to have an article written
about it he's just wrong
it's awesome yeah wikipedia's slavish
devotion to universe of reliable sources
rather than primary sources so he's
saying why can't i just tell you i'm a
great guy
right
he's like it's about me
you know
finally he talks about uh
talks about me which is obviously the
best part here
here let's go
i am experiencing this firsthand
over the past year my wikipedia entry
the top search result under my
name on google page one
second it's number two currently it's
between one and two i'm just curious he
mentions the first one what's number two
uh has been repeatedly defaced and
riddled with inaccurate information what
is inaccurate bro
what's inaccurate i mean you're suing me
for slander and the only thing you got
there is that i
[ __ ]
reported a headline in variety you know
what have i said inaccurate year a year
ago a youtube comedian with more than a
million followers named ethan klein
pirated and broadcasted video from a
boxing match
never rebroadcasted [ __ ]
my company produced for pay-per-view we
sued him to force him to remove the
video but in response he has waged an
all-out digital war against me creating
youtube videos attacking me comparing my
appearance to a disgraced hollywood
figure how dare he
make fun of my appearance
brad [ __ ] my wife harder anyway ethan's
been making fun of my looks
bryce get in there oh no
anyway he said really mean things about
me online
rallying his followers into action
on reddit and other forms and defacing
my wikipedia entry by use of hired
editors that is a salacious lie bro you
keep saying that
you keep saying that i'm not got nothing
to do with your wikipedia page
in response to this i have been forced
to sue ethan for defamation yet the
attacks continue
my wikipedia page still contains
incorrect and damaging information
wikipedia started as a good idea but now
it has become a
self-protective hive where editors egos
counterproductive rules and paid access
matters more than the truth
ryan cavanaugh guy who pays editors to
edit my [ __ ] page
god
what a loser bro what a [ __ ] loser
ryan kavanagh you're a [ __ ] loser bro
and somebody uh pointed out
yeah he said we sued him
uh so he admits that he was behind the
copyright suit and he said he didn't
have anything to do with it remember
there was like that period of time where
he was like i have no idea who he still
says that he put a declaration where he
goes i had no idea who he was he just
but wait where does he say
we sued him
to force him to remove the video
we yeah
oops i guess he's talking kind of the
royal week yeah royally
the chat really wants you to know that
they've given him a new uh nickname calf
calf
kavkav calf calf oh calf calf yeah
why is it that ryan looks like a
different person in every photo like
here's ryan okay
now here's ryan
okay
right and then here's ryan again who the
[ __ ] this guy
and then here's ryan again
i don't know who the [ __ ] this guy is
make up your mind bro
yo look at his awards and accolades
yep
look at that cuck of the year i've never
seen that one
i love that he's living in the past and
ignoring the fact that he utterly
bankrupted his
production company and in disgrace
leadership award right
showman of the year he really ride
riding that showman of the year 2011
for all it's worth man
so did you guys find any uh trailer
reviews that might uh when i went to the
apple app store um all the ones that i
was showing were ones that we've covered
before
okay like can you sort by new
yeah when you go to see all
the desktop version of their their app
store is kind of [ __ ] you can't really
but the ones that it shows you
i mean these are this is what it shows
you at least on the desktop version
there's one five star
a couple three and then a whole bunch of
ones well it's not a good app so i'm not
surprised
definitely not ethan klein this app
flows and it's ceo i do not know who
that guy is i don't know what that is
his app is so awkward
big fan of stand-up comedy specifically
kevin hart yeah we remember this one
yeah these are all ones that we've oh
you can't store it but i knew huh yeah
it doesn't like give you an option to
see the page i think on the phone give
them the phone you can yeah yeah i'm
telling them
maybe okay um still a 4.6 which is a
good really good rating
[Music]
when i first used that this is two stars
when i first used the app i use i had to
delete triller but then when i got
troller again i used my same account so
all my stuff should be there well it
isn't
and all this stuff
they still have access to your account
don't get this app interesting no that's
that sounds horrible
that's trailer on the app store yes
three stars video saving i can't say my
videos to my camera roll because they
won't completely finish
three stars that's fair
you see any one stars though
yeah these are all one stars one stars
uh trailer of the videos went from 60
seconds 45 seconds why you all so
jealous
do you see any five stars
um one star once there's not even any
five
oh five star yeah it's good okay well
there you go five star it's good okay
i personally think it's a one star
review
because you have to have people on a
platform for it to technically be social
media yeah
but i encourage you guys to try it and
give it your own review as always
you know
that's it
[Music]
yeah
yeah but i mean for but like yeah i mean
the man
and bryce hall's [ __ ] dp'ing his wife
with brad so it's kind of gnarly
so i get the discomfort
one star really buggy and full of ads
this is like tick tock if you want it to
be slow crash buggy and full of ads yeah
there you go sounds about right
that's kind of mirrors my experience
yeah
all right
but i love how maddie is about the
wikipedia page because i got nothing to
do with that [ __ ] bro
i lit like and that [ __ ] is so accurate
the man
ryan i got nothing to do with that
this is all this is your life this is
who you are
you know
did you or did you not
fake donate a million dollars to habitat
to humanity
in 2007 ryan cavanaugh presented habitat
humanity with the oversized check
pledging 1 million and announced he
would become a fundraising chair for the
charity however as of 2015 kavanaugh has
not yet donated the promised funds did
you or did you not do that
right yeah we're just asking questions
here
looking for some clarity
right if we can get some clarity we will
update uh the wikipedia page i'll create
an account and get in there and fix it
myself no no we're not touching the
wikipedia page
i mean
we have nothing to do with this page i
mean we don't have anything to do i'm
just saying if he
if he clarifies that
maybe someone is accurate who has
nothing to do with us we'll update it
okay maybe our boy throats
yeah throats would definitely
he's dedicated to the truth yeah that's
all it is that's all it is let's go to
the history i wonder what's going on
here i always like to see the uh
the battles
uh
let's see
uh april what's today april six so
here's our boy
um
this is a new name pabst
oh throats is still active my boy
yesterday we [ __ ] love throws
what a [ __ ] god dude
god papoke was there yeah god you
familiar names legends oh
oh wow butler the realtor just donated
69
dollars and said i would rather drink
ethan's pesto sauce than use triller
well well i'm right there with you buddy
i'd rather make more of that pesto sauce
than use trailer
um
i don't know why one is in red
uh paige does not exist
it's just a dead link dude this [ __ ] is
so confusing yeah it's it is it's really
confusing
but there you go guys that's the show
real quick yeah there's like this uh
interactive map of our place
and if you click on our area it links to
this ryan camera.com
no i just sent the link to you it's
pretty funny it's it's a third party
it's not the official red one but it's
really funny well whoever made it must
have
been a fantastic
so here's the interactive map for our
place
yeah so where's ours it's like i
remember it's so much further down to
the left if you just start it's the
podcast one that's uh yeah okay oh here
it is yeah right there yeah so it's like
a pokemon
slash h3
so we clicked that
i just clicked
the website on the right side website
well that is our website
yeah
wow this website is crazy
ours yeah it's cool yeah no ours is
crazy it's awesome the place one
how they put so much effort into that
yeah already wow already they put all
this together yeah
yeah
yeah that's amazing like everything
gee whiz
how'd they do all this so fast it's
probably a crowdfunder yeah or a crowd
sourced yeah yeah all right well shout
out ryan you know
actually i got to go home and review
some documents for the lawsuits no
lovely what i said lovely yeah yeah it
must be fun the defamation one
got to file some [ __ ] for it gotta go
give some notes
lovely
lovely lovely stuff
but uh there you go guys
oh god i wish i had access to my
instagram is nobody out here know anyone
on instagram
oh hang on
oh maybe i can maybe okay maybe i found
a lead for instagram
all right thank you guys see you on
friday we got brittany broski that's
gonna be a fun one eh
yo yo yo yo
let's freaking go
[Music]
see you all partners
[Music]
you